[Music]
it was the night before Christmas on a
set lit so bright a director was
planning an awesome Delight to make a
Marvel special with some holiday fun
that man was none other than director
James Gunn
it is the very first thing ever
conceived from Marvel Studios for Disney
plus it's a fantastic story vomited from
the brain of a Mad genius action on the
set of volume 2 James Gunn said we
should do a holiday special
Merry Christmas
we all had a laugh we thought that would
be great and then they growed it like
three days
[Music]
and the holiday special it's like
awesome this has been a real joyful
shoot because I get to work with a lot
of people I really love
I think audiences are really going to be
excited it's probably going to be played
every year for the rest of our lives
Kevin Bacon you're coming with us as a
Christmas present
[Music]